pablo inventó un juego llamado tres
tiradas para 10 tiras tres veces fundado
de seis lados si la suma de las tiradas
es mayor o igual que 10 ganas si es
menor que 10 pierdes cuál es la
probabilidad de ganar 3 tiradas para 10
hay varias formas en las que podemos
resolver esto la forma que vamos a usar
en este vídeo es tratar de encontrar una
probabilidad experimental vamos a
realizar varios experimentos para tratar
de ganar tres tiradas para 10 y
trataremos de encontrar la proporción en
la que ganamos
mientras más experimentos hagamos más
probable será que tengamos una mejor
aproximación a la probabilidad real
vamos a hacerlo y para ayudarnos voy a
generar por computadora una cadena de
números aleatorios que va de 0 a 9 la
forma en la que vamos a usar esto es
recuerden que estamos usando un dado de
6 lados por lo que el resultado puede
ser uno dos tres cuatro cinco o seis
para cada tirada en esta lista de
números aleatorios generada por
computadora
tenemos dígitos del 1 al 6 pero también
tenemos 0
7 8 y 9 así que para cada experimento
comenzaremos en la esquina superior
izquierda y vamos a considerar cada
dígito como una tirada si tenemos un
número inválido para una tirada de dado
como un 0 7 8 o 9
simplemente ignoraremos ese número como
una tirada no válida como si el dado se
hubiera caído de la mesa realizamos
varios experimentos tomaremos tres
tiradas las sumamos y veremos cuántos
podemos realizar para encontrar una
probabilidad experimental para ganar el
juego de pablo vamos a dibujar una tabla
aquí para registrar el experimento
la suma y si ganamos o no el juego
comencemos con el experimento número uno
en la primera tirada tuvimos un 1 en la
segunda tuvimos un 5 y en la tercera
tenemos un 6 hacemos la suma y nos da 12
así que si ganamos hagamos el
experimento número 2 en la primera
tirada tenemos un 6 en la segunda tirada
tenemos un 2 y en la tercera tirada
tenemos un 46 más 24 nos da 12 así que
si ganamos en este experimento hagamos
el experimento número 3 el primer dígito
no es válido la siguiente tirada nos da
6 el siguiente dígito no es válido la
segunda tirada nos da 3 luego tenemos un
1 válido luego otro no válido luego otro
no válido y finalmente tenemos la
tercera tirada que es 2 la suma nos da
11 por lo que ganamos este juego veamos
el cuarto experimento la primera tirada
es un 1 el siguiente no es válido la
segunda tirada es un 2 el siguiente no
es válido y la tercera tirada nos da 5
ganamos 1 + 2 + 5 es 8
que no ganamos sigamos con los
experimentos en el experimento 5 el
primer dígito no es válido luego tenemos
un 4 después un 3 y luego un 1 ganamos
la suma de 8 por lo que no ganamos
hagamos otra tabla como continuación de
la que tenemos vamos a hacer otros 5
experimentos en el experimento 6 tenemos
un 3 luego otro 3 y después un 2 lo que
nos da 8 y nos ganamos el juego
experimento 7 tenemos 12 el siguiente no
es válido luego tenemos un 3 y después
un 16 es menor que 10 por lo que tampoco
ganamos experimento 8 tenemos un 1 en la
primera tirada un 3 en la segunda tirada
el siguiente no es válido y tenemos un 5
en la tercera tirada ganamos no porque
la suma es 9 al principio ganamos varias
veces seguidas y ahora hemos perdido
varias veces seguidas pero continuemos
experimento 9 la primera tirada nos da 6
la segunda tirada nos da 4
todos estos no son válidos y tenemos un
5 en la tercera tirada ganamos si
ganamos ya que es mayor que 10 hagamos
el último experimento al menos el último
para este vídeo de hecho los invito para
que ustedes continúen con los
experimentos y vean si pueden encontrar
una mejor aproximación de la
probabilidad teórica de ganar haciendo
más experimentos para calcular la
probabilidad experimental experimento 10
la primera tirada nos da 5 la segunda
tirada nos da 2 los siguientes no son
válidos y la tercera tirada nos da 6 en
este último experimento ganamos sin duda
con base en estos diez experimentos cuál
es la probabilidad experimental de ganar
este juego de los diez experimentos
cuántos ganamos ganamos uno dos tres
cuatro y cinco así que tomando en cuenta
solamente estos diez experimentos
obtuvimos un claro 50%
creen ustedes que la probabilidad
teórica es realmente del 50% quizá
quieran continuar haciendo experimentos
una y otra vez quizá quieran hacer un
programa de cómputo para correr estos
experimentos y en lugar de tener diez
experimentos tener 10.000 experimentos y
poder acercarnos a la verdadera
probabilidad teórica